bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
session d'information voilà tout d'abord
ce que l'on peut retenir en ce vendredi
17 avril les 42 conseillers
départementaux ont voté ce vendredi le
budget du département un budget voté
dans la douleur avec une baisse annoncée
des dotations de l'état les vacances de
pâques ont démarré les forces de l'ordre
ne lésine pas sur les moyens de
prévention il était ce jeudi place de la
loi à versailles pour un contrôle
routier d'envergure journée portes
ouvertes à l'aérodrome de saint cyr
l'école ce dimanche baptêmes de l'air
spectacle de voltige présentation des
différents métiers de l'aéronautique et
d'autres surprises attendent les
visiteurs nous en parlons avec notre
invité dans quelques instants mais
d'abord donc le vote du budget primitif
pour les yvelines ce vendredi matin par
les 42 conseillers départementaux un
budget sous contrainte avec notamment la
diminution des dotations de l'état soit
une perte de 165 millions d'euros sur
trois ans dans ce contexte l'assemblée
présidée par pierre bédier a fait le
choix de ne pas augmenter les taux
d'imposition mais de faire des économies
en commençant par diminuer les
subventions aux villes ou aux
intercommunalités sur un budget d'un peu
plus d'un milliard d'euros et dans le
détail on retiendra que 530 millions
seront consacrés à la solidarité
autonomie des personnes âgées retour à
l'emploi et que 379 millions seront
dédiés à l'investissement dont 20
millions pour les collèges on écoute
pierre bédier le président ump du
conseil départemental des yvelines
toutes les marges de manoeuvre du
département on les a épuisés jusqu'au
dernier euro
donc ça veut dire que l'année prochaine
et donc ça commence dès maintenant il
nous faut mettre en oeuvre un plan
d'économies l'objectif est vraiment de
ne pas augmenter la fiscalité des
illinois mais le gouvernement socialiste
fait tout pour qu'on y parvienne pas ce
qu on nous rajoute des charges on
rajoute des obligations et donc c'est un
vrai casse-tête m'enfin on va essayer de
réussir ce pari et lors de la séance de
ce conseil départemental il a également
été adopté un plan numérique pour les
collèges encore de nouvelles
orientations pour renforcer le haut
débit envers les particuliers et les
professionnels
ce vendredi soir c'est le début des
vacances scolaires de pâques et du grand
chassé-croisé sur les routes les forces
de police se font voir en organisant des
contrôles routiers comme ce jeudi autour
de la place de la loi à versailles des
forces de l'ordre qui porte une
attention plus particulière sur le
comportement des deux
contrôles routiers pour ce pilote de
scooter il n'a pas ses papiers sur lui
peut écoper d'une amende de 22 euros je
crois que ça doit faire quinze ans je me
suis pas fait arrêter à bout je respecte
j'ai mes douze points je respecte le
code de la route quand même les
contrôles 6-3 pas systématique mais on
va dire
inopinés comme c'est le cas ici ben
c'est bien c'est ce qu'il faut pour
montrer qu'ils sont la preuve ce jeudi
autour de la place de la loi versailles
un lieu central de transit des véhicules
une trentaine de fonctionnaires entame
des contrôles routiers sur toutes sortes
d'infractions vitesse alcoolémie papier
ou plaques d'immatriculation par rapport
à la même période de l'année dernière le
département des yvelines a enregistré
deux morts de plus sur les routes la
cible prioritaire ce jour là les deux
roues dont le fait pas le choix des
voitures en fait le choix des taureaux
parce qu'aujourd'hui sur la zone police
l'immense majorité de nos morts sont des
morts en dose dû à une vitesse excessive
c'est à dire que 5 des décès qui ont
lieu sur la route en zone police
j'insiste et je ne parle pas de la zone
gendarmerie
sont déments d'euros dû à une vitesse
excessive c'est très très important
parce que même même les autres motos qui
font peut-être pas attention qui roule
un peu trop vite donc qui risquent leur
virée ce que la vie des piétons et et
de choquer les véhicules mais c'est bien
qu'ils se fassent contrôler qui voit là
un peu peur quand on se fait contrôler
oui c'est utile enfin là ça va mais non
c'est utile heureusement qu'ils sont là
est ce qu'on vous a reproché quelque
chose oui j'ai pas mon a depuis le début
de l'année 3205 contrôles routiers ont
eu lieu sur les routes du département la
mobilisation des services de l'état
depuis 2010 a permis d'économiser 17 vie
c'est très important de les sauver et
moins 400 dans l'accident comme blessés
donc ça prouve bien que l'action sur le
terrain
répression comme prévention aussi porte
ses fruits ce jeudi les contrôles
routiers ne concernait pas que la place
de la loi 20 autres points étaient mis
en place au même moment dans le
département cent dix-huit policiers
renforcés de six policiers municipaux
ont contrôlé 807 personnes et 103
infractions ont été relevées
ce dimanche l'aérodrome de saint cyr
l'école va exceptionnellement ouverts et
ouvrir ses portes et pour en parler
servent nos vies cchb bonjour vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'association
saint cyr aviation partage c'était une
journée totalement gratuite est offerte
aux particuliers avec des baptêmes de
l'air des exercices de voltige de
stimuler simulateur de vol bref il ya
beaucoup de choses on va aussi parler du
métier de l'aéronautique
justement pour nous donner envie à ce
que pouvait nous dire ce que l'on pourra
faire et voir surtout dimanche entre 10
heures et 17 heures à l'aérodrome de
saint cyr l'école alors d'abord merci
pour votre invitation effectivement
notre association saint cyr aviation
partage est une association toute jeune
qui a été créé en
2013 pour ouvrir l'aérodrome de saint
cyr l'école vers tous ceux qui ne sont
pas pilote et qui ont envie de partager
la passion de l'aéronautique et de
l'aviation je crois que c'est important
de que les pilotes puissent rencontrer
les noms pilote puisqu'un pilote après
tout c'est un passionné d'aéronautique
un passionné d'aviation et que tout
simplement il est devenu pilote en plus
donc nous allons faire une plateforme
des changes sur saint cyr l'école avec
un certain nombre de conférences avec
une attractivité surtout pour les jeunes
pour qu'ils découvrent un monde eux
passionnant qu'est le monde de
l'aéronautique et puis également pour
faire rayonner le terrain de saint cyr
l'école aura des baptêmes de l'air par
exemple il y aura des baptêmes de l'air
il ya accès aux baptêmes de l'air mais
d'une manière tout à fait gratuite ils
vont pouvoir accéder déjà au simulateur
de vol pour pouvoir s'initier au vol il
ya deux simulateurs de vol qui seront
c'est gratuit les bananes de l'ère des
baptêmes de l'air cemaa en fait c'est
gratuit c'est à voir avec chacun des
aéro club du terrain ya douze aéro clubs
qui vont offrir la possibilité d'avoir
des baptêmes de l'air et puis il ya un
jeu concours où il y aura des baptêmes
de l'air à gagner des baptêmes de l'air
c'est sur quel type d'appareil cd dont
disposent les types d'appareils dont
disposent les erreurs qu'ils s'arrachent
des avions d abbey lincoln et des avions
de tourisme des avions légers il faut
noter aussi qui aura là une présence
exceptionnelle de de dorine bourneton
c'est la première pilote professionnel
handicapés oui c'est une l'auteur de
marennes non c'est une sorte de marennes
c'est une pilotes handicapés c'est
quelqu'un qui est merveilleux elle a un
merveilleux sourire elle a eu un
accident d'avion alors qu elle était
passagère elle a décidé de passer ses
brevets elle l'a elle fait de la voltige
aujourd'hui nous réserve certainement
une très très belle surprise pour le
bourget en 2015 cette année et elle sera
là et il y aura des avions d'handicapés
qui seront là parce que nous avons
aujourd'hui des héros clubs qui sont des
aéro clubs spécialisés dans le handicap
avec des avions équipés de m'aligner au
lieu de palonnier et nous aurons des
pilotes handicapés qui sont sur le
terrain vous avez parlé de voltige aura
des démonstrations de voltige avec pour
la première fois je crois que les avions
qui vont équiper justement les pilotes
qui participeront en outre en août
prochain au championnat du monde qui
aura lieu à châteauroux oui pour avoir
les premiers alors ce qu'ils feront des
avoirs qui est effectivement notre
équipe de france de voltige détient le
titre mondial depuis 2013 à peu près
toutes les catégories et sur les
championnats donc cette fois-ci de
château en 2013 championnat du monde ils
vont être équipés d'un tout nouvel avion
qui vient d'être certifié et qui fera sa
première démonstration sur le terrain de
saint cyr l'école
c'était pour la cigale et oui c'est une
première - si on veut encourager les
voltigeurs français qu'ils participent
en août prochain à châteauroux il faut
venir ce dimanche sur l'aérodrome de
saint cyr l'école il ya aussi haut
puisque vous parliez d'avion il y aura
aussi lifan à la lifan sap à présent il
y aura une maquette je crois qu'il
aurait mal de m il sera présenté par bus
groupe pour présenter lifan ans pour
ceux qui savent la lifan qu'est ce que
c'est je vous laisse voilà il y aura il
y aura des ingénieurs effectivement qui
seront là pour expliquer que l'évolution
aujourd'hui c'était une évolution vers
les nouvelles technologies
ce sont des avions qui ce sera un avion
école qui un avion électrique un
sélective en avion électrique
effectivement l'avion électrique donc ça
aussi c'est une nouveauté une première
où on présentera sa en région parisienne
alors en plus de ces baptêmes de l'air
de c2c voltige de sebo teaser qui seront
présents plus de l'ifan il y aura aussi
à des stands qui seront dédiés aux
métiers de l'aéronautique
oui aux métiers de l'aéronautique parce
que c'est très important si on veut
attirer les jeunes dans ce métier de
l'aéronautique que ce soit non pas
forcément du pilotage que ce soit de la
mécanique ou d'autres métiers et il est
évident que nous avons fait appel à des
sociétés qui sont spécialisés dans ce
domaine et qui vont offrir une
visibilité sur tous les métiers de
l'aéronautique je pense notamment à
thales à safran qui seront présents sur
le terrain pour ouvrir aux jeunes les
perspectives d'avenir on comprend que
c'est assez large en fait votre journée
portes ouvertes et c'est pas fini ce que
je voudrais un mot sur votre grand
projet aussi que l'installation d'un
musée la direction de l'aviation civile
a donné son accord il faut maintenant un
espace pour accueillir ce musée mais
qu'est ce qu'il y aura dans ce musée
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
aujourd'hui c'est pour faire en fait
parce que là on est on parle du futur on
parle de l'ifan ont parlé des voltigeurs
ça c'est le futur mais là et retombe de
saint cyr c'est toute une histoire et ce
musée ce serait pour au tracé je présume
l'histoire de l'aérodrome alors ce musée
est un c'est lié à l'histoire vous savez
que l'histoire de l'aérodrome de saint
cyr saint cyr a commencé en 1909 avec
santos dumont qui a rejoint saint cyr
but qu il a fait 5 km en 5 minutes ça a
été un exploit à l'époque et puis c'est
devenu une grande base grande base
aéronautique
de l'armée de l'air une base de l'armée
de l'air il y avait des recherches il y
avait de la mécanique c'était une très
grande plateforme est tellement grande
que vous avez en 1911
le roi de serbie pierre premier qui est
venu visiter saint cyr vous aviez en
1912 l'état-major russe qui est venu
visiter saint cyr et en 1922 vous avez
les premiers aéro clubs qui sont nés à
saint cyr l'école et partant de ce
principe nous avons avec claire farman
qui est le descendant d'une famille
illustre au niveau de pilotes et de
constructeur d'avions et pia pharma nous
avons imaginé de créer un musée mais
amusé atypique amusé sur la mécanique où
nous allons montrer aux jeunes
toutes les pièces d'un avion comment
s'est construit comment c'est fait
comment savez-vous lui pour essayer de
les attirer avec caf rahmane on a eu une
expérience assez remarquable sur un
jeune qui était en échec scolaire il
était intelligent mais il n'avait pas
envie de travailler et tout d'un coup il
a découvert l'aéronautique il a
découvert la mécanique et puis il s'est
dit eh bien c'est ça qui me plaît il
s'est mis à travailler ça n'a pas été
une contrainte ça a été une facilité
pour lui s'est mis à travailler et puis
il a réussi aujourd'hui il a un métier
qui le passionne donc nous allons ouvrir
ce musée il sera évolutif il va évoluer
au cours n'ont pas encore où mais c'est
sûr assez sur la place assise nous avons
vu à paris mais après l'accord sous
forme de saint cyr il faut encore
déterminer les emplacements et finaliser
le projet mais nous le commenceront très
rapidement et on vous invitera à ce
moment là et donc dimanche on pourra
avoir quelques pièces qui pourrait jouer
dimanche ont intégré ces joueurs
quelques caisses on ira même un peu plus
loin pour vous montrer le recyclage
d'une pièce
soit en objets décoratifs soit tout
simplement
quasiment en oeuvre d'art avec du
polissage donc pierre bleue pièces
brutes et puis pièces travaillées merci
beaucoup a service est revenu sur pato
des personnes soit 17 jours et j'espère
que
oui on pense bien des petits mots qui
m'ont qui ont dû sa fiche est donc une
journée portes ouvertes ce dimanche à
l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école c'est
de 10h à 17h il est important de
rappeler que tout gratuit si vous voulez
assister à des voltiges notamment c'est
certainement le plus peut-être le plus
impressionnant vous pourrez aussi faire
du simulateur de vol les baptêmes de
l'arçon sont payants en fonction des
tarifs des aéro club mais en tout cas
pour voir les voltigeurs en vrai
l'équipe de france on peut la voir en
vrai ce dimanche à l'aérodrome de saint
cyr d'école merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur le papillon nous allons maintenant
poursuivre ce journal avec un retour sur
les faits marquants de la semaine
écoulée
une page politique pour continuer ce
journal ancien ministre de nicolas
sarkozy député des yvelines valérie
pécresse vient de lancer officiellement
sa campagne pour la présidence de la
région ile de france en cas de victoire
elle démissionnera de ses autres mandats
explications wilfred richy maxime le
maine
une arrivée en musique au milieu d'une
foule de 2000 personnes depuis la seine
saint denis valérie pécresse a voulu
marquer les esprits et adressé un
message aux électeurs elle est la seule
à pouvoir battre les socialistes elle
lors des régionales en île de france
programmée en décembre et ce gâchis
c'est le bilan de la gauche c'est
l'échec du trio jean paul huchon marie
pierre de la gontrie son bras droit
depuis tant d'années et de la verte
emmanuelle cosse tous les franciliens le
dise on vit moins bien en ile de france
en 2015 qu'en 1998 cette ferveur me
m'encourage énormément mais vous savez
je pense qu'à une envie d'alternance une
envie de changement la région ile de
france c'est le moteur de l'avion france
et si nous changeons la région je ferai
à laboratoire de l'alternance avec moins
d'impôts avec plus de logements plus de
transport et puis aussi plus encore un
grand pacte régional en faveur de la
ruralité un soutien à l'accession
sociale ou encore un plan orsec pour les
transports figure dans ses propositions
mais bien qu'en tête dans les sondages
ces derniers mois l'inconnu front
national et la présence d'une liste udi
pourrait néanmoins hypothéquer la
victoire à l'épée créé c'est d'abord une
battante la vie est difficile
chacun de ceux qui sont ici le savent
bien dans la vie vous battre
rien n'est acquis
rien n'est donné soutenu par nicolas
sarkozy mais aussi par françois fillon
et sur le plan local par pierre bédier
président du conseil départemental qui
avaient tous fait le déplacement valérie
pécresse souhaite donc une union dès le
premier tour avec lui des pascal abus
talent parce que allah de la conviction
parce qu'elle est pas si l'élu de france
parce que elle a un sens
de l'intérêt général qui est sain et
dont on a besoin ici en ile de france
d'ici à l'été l'ancien ministre actuel
député entend parcourir les 100
circonscriptions de l'île de france
et les dates des élections régionales
ont été dévoilés cette semaine ce sera
les 6 et 13 décembre prochains
toujours en politique henri paillet
annoncé qu'il démissionnerait de son
fauteuil de maire en désaccord notamment
sur l'intégration de sa commune au sein
de l'acas qui ce samedi c'était donc
chose faite il a laissé sa place sans
surprise à son adjoint à l'économie jean
pierre sauvestre et retour sur ce
conseil municipal empli d'émotion et
clorinde parfait mélanie poquet
on ripaille ouvrant son écharpe après
trois décennies à la tête de la
municipalité de coignières l'image est
forte l'ancien maire passe la main à son
adjoint aux affaires économiques jean
pierre ses vestes réélu à 21 voix contre
6 par le conseil municipal je
m'attendais à cette élection ce matin et
j'en suis j'en suis très heureux je sais
que succéder à henri pailleux c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est quelque
chose de pas très aisé tout de même
parce que c'était un personnage au sein
de la commune et il l'a fait au cours de
ses trente ans de mandat des choses
extraordinaires sur la commune il
prendre la suite de ripailles eux c'est
c'est quelque chose de peu un peu
difficile tout de même mais je sens que
j'ai le j'ai le courage d'assumer de la
succession figure locale henry pailloux
maire ump avait annoncé il ya quelques
mois sa future démission opposé à
l'entrée de coignières dans la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il a préféré
quitter son poste mais continuera à
siéger au conseil municipal où les
passagers vers et de quitter
fonction est sale que j'exerce dont 86
et donc effectivement c'est avec une
grande émotion que j'ai pris la décision
de passer le relais parce que j'estime
qu'à 75 ans il faut être raisonnable
lorsqu'on part de la deuxième 200 12e
position parmi des villes les plus
riches département et qu'en trente ans
on l'amène à la deuxième place derrière
lgi japon est fier du côté de
l'opposition cette décision est
critiquée c'est ce qu'affirme didier
fischer représentants de l'opposition il
s'est également présenté à l'élection de
premier magistrat ce départ moi me
faisais l'impression d'un déni de
démocratie c'est d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de quoi n'y a rien qui l'ont
exprimé assez clairement dans la mesure
on se présente à une élection et que
l'on dit qu'on va aller jusqu'au bout
puisque toute la campagne a été un petit
peu aussi fondée là dessus on va aller
jusqu'au bout et bien
on voit que neuf mois après l'ordre de
cesser sa déclaration des voeux il nous
annonce sa démission donc il ya quelque
part je dirais une forme de trahison
l'opposition a néanmoins salué le
travail d'henri pailleux didier fischer
s'est dit prêt à travailler en bonne
intelligence avec le nouveau maire le
prochain dossier important sera
évidemment l'entrée de la ville dans
l'intercommunalité
l'éducation cette semaine était
consacrée à l'école maternelle
l'occasion de faire le point notamment
sur l'intégration des enfants de 2 ans
dans les yvelines 30 établissements
participent à cette expérimentation dont
l'école hélène-boucher attrape où s'est
rendu notre équipe pas
l'école maternelle à partir de 2 ans la
ville de trappes s'est lancé dans ce
projet en 2013 aujourd'hui quatre
établissements de la commune dont
l'école hélène boucher sont ouverts ces
classes spécifiques objectif développer
la socialisation des enfants dans les
quartiers jugés sensibles on s'est rendu
compte que après en 4 que 73% de
l'enfant de trappes n'était pas
socialisée c'est énorme donc ils
arrivent à l'école à trois ans ils n'ont
pas de langage très fourni non pas le la
sociabilisation ils ne connaissent pas
certains d'entre eux ne sortent pas de
chez eux donc il fallait intervenir au
plus vite et au plus tôt de façon à ce
que les enfants soient socialiser après
le langage pour développer le
vocabulaire des enfants plusieurs
ateliers sont programmés et sessions
sont animés du lundi au vendredi par
trois encadrants une enseignante une
atsem une auxiliaire de puériculture des
activités motrices beaucoup parce qu'ils
en ont besoin mais après des êtres des
activités de manipulation des
des activités de transvasement de la
peinture de la pâte à modeler beaucoup
de choses qui vont les attirer en fait
les coins jeux la dînette les poupées
voilà ce programme concerne une
trentaine d'établissements dans le
département des yvelines
un dispositif qui pourrait être étendue
dans les prochaines années alors c'est
un programme qui est assez développée
dans le département des yvelines on
souhaite le renforcer dans le même
esprit de collaboration avec l'ensemble
des partenaires avec des compétences
multiples bien entendu et peut-être
aussi gagné au delà des territoires de
l'éducation prioritaire où il est
davantage installés de manière à
renforcer la scolarisation des deux ans
qui mérite de l'être dans le département
l'école maternelle à partir de 2 ans un
coup 220000 euros par classe chaque
année
du 14 au 16 avril se sont déroulées les
4e rencontres de l'autonomie à le thème
de cette année de l'accompagnement et le
prendre soin des personnes âgées ou en
situation de handicap et préserver sa
santé passe aussi par l'activité
physique un atelier était proposée
d'ailleurs ce jeudi matin yolaine thorez
elodie moine un peu d'exercice tous les
jours pour améliorer sa condition
physique c'est le message que tente de
faire passer l'éducateur sportif ce
matin dans le cadre des rencontres de
l'autonomie il apprend à ces personnes
âgées ou en situation de handicap et
quelques exercices à faire seul chez soi
est toujours en adoptant la bonne
posture même maintenant dans la pratique
sportive c'est quelque chose sur lequel
on n'insiste pas on retrouve beaucoup de
cours collectifs et dans les cours
collectifs malheureusement on n'a pas le
temps de corriger les personnes il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de défauts dans la
posture est ce qui entraîne plus tard
les problèmes donc effectivement des
problèmes qui s'accumulent avec les
problèmes de la vieillesse ne pas
marcher plus de deux heures par jour
faire des étirements régulièrement le
coach en profite pour prodiguer de bons
conseils je suis venu pour un petit peu
nous sortir un peu d'isolement
notre vie habituel et puis aussi
le thème l'atelier m'intéresser au
niveau de la santé active j'ai trouvé
d'ailleurs que ça faisait bien travaillé
tous tous les organes du corps le coeur
le souffle des étirements j'ai trouvé
très intéressante je vais me tenir le
plus longtemps possible bien et puis
j'ai par tous les moyens je sais de
faire le maximum quoi d'autres ateliers
étaient proposés tout au long de la
journée pour ces quatrièmes rencontres
de l'autonomie un rendez vous que vous
pourrez retrouver l'année prochaine
est toujours en santé samedi 18 avril
c'est la journée mondiale contre la
maladie de parkinson un colloque est
organisé pour échanger autour de la
maladie pour prévenir les ruptures de
soins est faire avancer la recherche ce
colloque a donc lieu demain samedi de
14h à 17h30 à la maison de la chimie à
paris et je vous propose de découvrir le
dernier clip de sensibilisation de
l'association france parkinson
je m'appelle alexis j'ai la maladie de
parkinson nous sommes cent cinquante
mille malades en france notre esprit
nous dit devancé mais notre corps nous
en empêche
on est emprisonné
chaque mouvement est une épreuve en
nielsen
pourtant des solutions existent pour
libérer les sondes libérer la recherche
libérer les malades vous pouvez nous
aider
ensemble libérant le mouvement
retrouvons en août sur france parkinson
point fr
voilà donc journée mondiale de lutte
contre la maladie de parkinson ce sera
demain samedi ce journal est maintenant
terminé merci de votre attention rendez
vous de l'information locale lundi en
direct à 18h je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end